we are just four days before the Iowa
caucus and the race is tightening
between the top Democratic contenders a
new Monmouth University poll just out
yesterday found former Vice President
Joe Biden has a narrow lead over senator
Bernie Sanders there but really it is a
dead heat as the gap is within the
margin of error on that poll ed O'Keefe
is in Des Moines for us edie good
morning what are you hearing from
islands well Toni good morning many
voters here tell us they remain
undecided that same poll you mentioned
found that nearly half of likely
caucus-goers say they might still change
their mind before Monday night just the
latest proof that this is still almost
anybody's race to win every four years
democracy begins in Iowa former Vice
President Joe Biden and mayor Pete Budaj
a are among the only candidates getting
face time with Iowa voters as other
contenders serve at the impeachment
trial
Budda judge is focused on turning out a
broad coalition of voters and I'm
meeting lots of what I like to call
future former Republicans who are just
as upset about what's happening in this
White House as I am the four senators
running for president or trial jurors
have a choice to make in the coming days
do they vote to hear from additional
witnesses and risk being off the
campaign trail on caucus day I took an
oath and I will be there as long as that
trial needs me would I rather be
campaigning in Iowa in the last week I
would during breaks in the trial in
recent days Amy Klobuchar snuck in a
quick trip to western Iowa and Elizabeth
Warren was there on Sunday Bernie
Sanders is relying on thousands of
volunteers this map here it's a few
blocks down
Sanders is increasing popularity here is
worrying moderate Democrats who fear he
could win the caucus a group called
Democratic majority for Israel is
spending nearly seven hundred thousand
dollars on ads that invoked the Senators
recent health troubles I do have some
concerns about Bernie Sanders health
considering the fact he did have a heart
attack
that attack ad is working to senator
Sanders his benefit they flagged it for
his supporters and he raised 1.3 million
dollars in the day after it was released
now Democrats don't have Iowa to
themselves today President Trump he's
holding a campaign rally here in
Moin tonight Tony the gloves are coming
off Thank You ed now I want to tell you
there is nobody standing behind you now
just a day or two ago
Vice President Biden snuck up on you
there is an alive appearance on this
very Network what was that like what's
unlike anything you usually see on the
news look we had permission to be there
but it was a small room so there was
always a chance that we might be
speaking a little too loudly and clearly
we rattled him so he felt the need to
come over and make a cameo on the
evening news
I've never seen you unprepared but I
think you were caught off guard by that
one let me just say it was very funny
visually I'm curious about what it felt
to you being there could you feel a more
sense him coming we we had this screen
we call it return in the business and so
I saw him coming and when I saw him
coming out of the corner of my eye I had
no idea where this was headed all right
thank you very much